fermer les p'tits p'tits commerces de
chez nous en deux jours et demi deux
jours en une nuit et une nuit
tu sais que tu es très célèbre en
France tu sais ça ben je suis ravie
de l'entendre donc on connait Machine Gun Kelly
on sait House of a shell les p'tits
magasins sont loin on sait [ __ ] de maman
tu as eu des soucis en France avec [ __ ] de
banane oui il y a eu de la censure à
un moment une relation entre euh Ma
Barker et ses fils et tu as été obligé
de venir en France pour  discutez avec les
capteurs oui c'est vrai et vous avez
bien gagné j'ai fait un petit compromis mais c'est
en fait un excellent et vous avez fait deux
anges sauvages oui c'est le premier
de Motors combien de films avez-vous avez-
vous bien tourné en tant que réalisateur que j'ai réalisé
environ 50 peut-être 55 je ne me souviens même pas
ouais et j'en ai produit environ 200. eh
bien j'ai commencé au milieu des années 50 et je
vais toujours dans 89. ouais et saison à
la gamme de combien combien de films par
an c'est varié  quelques années aussi bas que
cinq ou six l'année dernière j'ai fait 22 films c'est
vrai que tu fermes les p'tits euh les
p'tits magasins de photos en deux jours et
demi deux jours en une nuit et une nuit c'est
vrai tu es vraiment mon record pour
les producteurs  non probablement cependant quand j'ai
fini bobtown le scénariste ouais
c'est un bon ami à moi qui a dit tu dois te
souvenir que Roger faire un film n'est pas comme
une rencontre sur piste donc je ne suis jamais allé aussi
vite mais pourquoi as-tu fait ça parce que tu
avais si peu  argent
partiellement j'avais juste un peu d'
argent et partiellement juste comme une blague pour
voir si je pouvais le faire ouais alors toi tu as
aidé beaucoup de gens à démarrer dans
le métier sont
pour commencer une nouvelle carrière nous allons commencer l'
habituel  interview je te donnerai des noms
et tu me diras ce que tu en penses
ok t'es prêt je suis prêt
[Musique]
donc Vincent Price car tu as fait beaucoup d'
adaptations d'Edgar avec lui maintenant un
grand monsieur et un très bon acteur un
homme très sensible Peter Laurie est un
grand ou était un grand talent il n'a jamais
connu ses répliques quand il est venu sur le plateau
mais c'était un grand talent ouais
basil Rathbone quand j'ai travaillé avec lui
était très vieux
il était un peu raide à cette époque
mais avait été un acteur majeur il n'était pas
que vous savez je pense euh je pense que son âge l'
avait ralenti quand il vivait avec
moi Murray Scala Boris Karloff était
un peu le même que Vincent Price il
avait été formé dans une
tradition théâtrale anglaise et  était un acteur très bien
formé et préparé,
vous avez produit son premier film maintenant oui,
puis un autre film, euh, nous avons tourné à
Singapour Saint Jack Peter Mcdanovich est l'
un des meilleurs talents de l'
industrie cinématographique, il a parfois
eu sa propre manière
Brian De Palma est  un homme très varié,
ses films ont comment dois-je dire suivi
un certain canal mais je pense qu'il est
capable de sortir de ce canal
et de faire un travail plus enterré
et Jack Nicholson Jack Nicholson est
génial Jack a travaillé avec moi pendant de nombreuses
années le meilleur  elle, je peux parler de Jack
Nicholson, c'est quand il a commencé, j'ai
dit Jack si tu es aussi bon que tu le penses
et tu es aussi bon que je pense que
tu l'es comment se fait-il que je sois le seul réalisateur
qui t'embauche
et  Jack a dit de lui donner du temps, ils
seront tous après moi finalement
oui il travaillait dans une école de théâtre
que je fréquente à Berkeley mais comment avez-
vous décidé que vous c'était lui j'ai vu
Jack faire des improvisations en classe et j'ai
fait de l'improvisation avec lui  et c'est
un homme très inventif très rapide
et très créatif mais en même temps
très très sérieux
est vraiment un produit de New York ouais le
premier film qu'il a fait pour moi nous
tournions sur place dans le sud des États-Unis
et je pense que c'est un hommage à  lui
mais il a su s'adapter au Sud
mais il est vraiment à son meilleur quand il
reflète la ville il connaît vraiment
la démence certain pour vous oui Francis a été
mon assistant pendant un certain temps puis a
continué à diriger pour moi puis est passé à
un  carrière très brillante la carrière de francis
a connu des hauts et des bas et je pense qu'elle
remontera très rapidement
je me soucie
tellement plus il a pris bien soin de mon
argent ta dernière chose était à propos du
baron d'Estroven le Baron Rouge ouais
c'était en 1970 et tu vas faire un autre
film maintenant oui est-il heureux que tu me
poses cette question parce que je pense
après  car après 19 ans je vais recommencer à
réaliser cet été oh quel genre
de film un film très étrange c'est un
récit de l'histoire de Frankenstein mais
ça commence au 21e siècle et
remonte au 19e siècle c'est
Frankenstein dans la science-fiction c'est de la
science-fiction  c'est de l'horreur c'est un
peu un commentaire politique et c'est
un peu un film religieux ça
va être un film très étrange quel âge as-
tu j'ai 63 ans.
[Musique]